hello thanks for joining us today we're
going to be talking about building a
large-scale migration Factory in Google
Cloud my name is Nick Taylor and I'm are
immediately for migration in our
professional services to you and with me
today it's been everyone been a guy here
I'm the migration global practice lead
for patient services organization thanks
guys so I'm going to talk about three
steps in building a large-scale
migration faction and how to get that
infrastructure into GCP first of those
steps is building a business case so
understanding the value of a migration
why you're doing it and what will
achieve for your business
step two is about establishing
foundations but a technical and
non-technical and preparing for scale
picking most web applications and
getting some infrastructure moved and
then the first step is about scaling
infection so how to industrialize the
process move large volumes of workloads
so first off building that business case
even though it's almost inevitable
you'll save money with a cloud migration
any effort any change requires effort
and that means cost so we need to
understand really where the value
realization is and how you're going to
save money and gain efficiencies in that
car migration so let's take a look at
how we understand the value of that
migration so it's true to say that the
majority of IT budgets are allocated
today to maintaining the status quo
looking after your current
infrastructure so what we need to think
about is how we can lower your run costs
to free up free up money for innovation
migrations are always disruptive so it's
important to get executive sponsorship
enjoy your map migration and
demonstrating those soundings are a good
step in that process so we think about
building our migration return on
investment calculation we look at your
houses run rate - what are you spending
today on infrastructure or maintaining
your infrastructure and on software
licensing on people who manage that
infrastructure also the access
themselves data centers land rent things
like power on the other side we compare
that with what they're likely to be
spending and so what's the anticipated
ramp of spending GCP
what would it cost you to get the
migrations moved over and one of the
time I look like too deep
your existing infrastructure so when
will you start to realize that value
when we look at your current run costs
and we think about the inventory of your
infrastructure and understanding from a
real sort of fact-based way where you're
spending today and how how easy it will
be to do the migration so we use
inventory tooling for that you can see
examples of some of our preferred
patterns on the screen those tools we'll
look at the server's themselves so
what's their size and shape CPU memory
and so on and also how well they're
utilized as well as the dependencies in
between them
at this point we'll also look at things
like storage networking security costs
and you need to consider things like
logging and backups as well and we add
into that other supporting costs
building maintenance power cooling
software licensing and so on as we build
the cost model then we think about the
other side of the business case which is
how you're going to reload a van having
a better drive efficiencies through
cloud migration the first of these is
infrastructure optimization and grid
computing is a great example of this it
mattered risk calculations that run for
8 hours overnight five days a week so
your production environment that is idle
for 16 hours a day during the week and
all from the complete weekend meanwhile
your disaster recovery environment is
idle the whole time so actually you're
barely using your infrastructure we've
seen banks that make 80% savings when
they move those calculations to the
cloud but just using infrastructure on
demand without making any changes to
their applications although that's
magnified that's true for disaster
recovery in general and you don't need a
full sized ER environment always running
you can spin that up as you need it in
the cloud there are other savings here
for infrastructure things like storage
optimization considering backup strategy
and just adjusting your infrastructure
to peak load the second thing to
consider here is operational efficiency
so Google cloud gives consolidated
availability performance running
monitoring all the infrastructure that
you deploy and similarly we recommend
using infrastructure as code for
deployment of both servers themselves
and all the supporting infrastructure
firewalls and so on by doing so you're
realizing significant operational
savings also things like automated patch
management and consolidating security
totally mean that you'll say further
when you think about modernizing
applications that's the third step here
and refactoring applications
cloud later it means you'll take
advantage of both of those things just
infrastructure when you need it and also
that operational efficiency of
continuous deployment and consolidated
cognitive - so when we bring all those
things together we build a complete
value model for your cloud migration
both the current and future operating
costs gathered from tooling and then
data from across the organization all
the benefits that clout can bring
together those things show your expected
returns you'll see here's a bit of a
hunt for migration cost inevitably enter
your dual running infrastructure and
perhaps paying for services whether ours
or a partner or even just your own time
in doing that migration but we can help
you offset that migration hub as you
migrate and maximize value as early as
you can
so far we spoke about cost savings but
what other value you can get by
migrating to the cloud cloud migration
how to unlock business battle so as you
migrated data into the cloud often
you're seeing queries take seconds where
they used to take days so that access to
real-time data enables you to make more
strategic business decisions based on
real time data and also allows access to
that tooling and that data and to things
like machine learning they're possible
in addition it also enables business
agility so we described that kind of
rapid software life cycle that continues
to flow and means typically lower time
to lower time to market for new features
and new innovation in the business and
then finally Google Cloud is one of the
most robust so now a global security and
our world-class Network used for our own
product is now available to you meaning
there's less likelihood of business
disruption from IT service outages so
you've thought about a clear business
case now you've got approval to move
forward with your migration what next
so we start to look at how to build the
foundations in the cloud as you'd expect
from Google we think about migration
more than just about technology you
might need to change your organisation
as well when you're thinking about
adopting the cloud to really gain the
benefit we use the Google cloud adoption
framework as the core of our operating
model in the cloud and how do you
understand the implications of that car
migration how to get the best out of it
what might be tap New York message the
kind of adoption framework is made of
four key themes learn lead scale and
secure that you see here on the screen
learn means of course learning new
skills and training
and technology but it also changes the
way you learn cloud resources are cheap
and disposable so it means people can
learn and innovate safely through
hackathons and experimentation
leadership means of course executive
sponsorship for the program and a clear
vision but it also means sharing
knowledge of good practice across the
organization
we recommend something like a center of
excellence or a cloud platform team to
help achieve that and this kind of
psychological safety and a reduction of
silos across the organization as well
scale means using covered option to
build repeatable scalable processes so
we talked about DevOps and continuous
integration and infrastructure is
covered here to mean it much easier for
you to scale but wanted ease of
infrastructure with lesser operational
security means trust really trust in the
deployment of the cloud we think
typically that cloud security is
stronger than on-premise security but
it's different you need to think about
how your security model watch and so how
do you know where you are with those
four key things we take that model and
we help you do a cloud maturity
assessment across each of the themes
we'll look at whether you're taking a
tactical strategic or transformational
view or command option so where are you
today and how far do you want to go as
an organization and the change that you
might need to undertake will help you
make recommendations allowing you to set
up your cloudy and really get the best
out of it is use behind that assessment
can be undertaken by us in our
professional services team through
partners where you can do it yourself
using a self-service tool and the URL is
on the screen
so once you've understood that cloud
maturity and where you are on Lotus
machines you'll restart to understand
the operating model you want to build in
the cloud so those translate into those
themes you see here on the left about
platform engineering and governance and
building up operating one we take the
lessons from the maturity assessment and
build that cloud operating model through
your organization can take to all those
themes and establishes a set of controls
and services that allow you to operate
comfortably in fact most of that as I
mentioned sits in the cloud center of
excellence the more cloud platform team
but spreads out across the organization
you'll see here on the right where that
cloud center of excellence it's between
your application teams on the right and
the
infrastructure on the left if you were
devil tea you might just adopt the card
straight away within those guardrails
but for lots of legacy applications and
the focus of our discussion today we
recommend the migration factory team but
some of people and processes that can
help migrate applications at scale so
once you feel about organizational
structure we think about the technical
foundations that you need based on those
controls that you've defined to automate
the deployment of your infrastructure so
you need that secure place to to move
your infrastructure consider whether it
looks like your on-premises state or
whether it needs to evolve things like
identity management security controls
obviously networking so establishing the
technical connectivity between your
on-premise environment in the cloud but
also the structure of your network
whether it looks like again on-premise
whether you're using a new cloud native
ways of looking instrumentation means
defining the baseline of all of your
monitor your infrastructure making sure
it's available and performs at least as
well as if they've on-premise when you
move it to the lab and finally of course
it's really important to think about
cost control it used to be that your
procurement department would buy
infrastructure or improve that perhaps
once a year whereas in the cloud that's
much more dynamic so understanding the
impact of that across your organization
is really cool
remember our focus for this is as
infrastructure as code we use our pile
foundations toolkit as a common baseline
set of controls and automation for
deploying all of that configuration it
allows you to rapidly deploy
infrastructure but also all of the
supporting guardrails and controls
everything is there in version
controlled and really easy to deploy
if you choose not to do that in an
automated way when you first get started
in TCP we also have an enterprise
onboarding checklist which is a
step-by-step manual process to help you
establish similar controls for your
environment once you've got that
environment it will set up we help you
in valuate the migration path for each
of your workloads we have an overall
approach that's really forced out here
assess plan migrate unoptimized when we
think about migration there are two key
approaches for that very hosting and
re-platforming we use our migration
factory approached the focus on our
discussion today but we also think about
with factoring applications and how you
change and modernize them so when we
look at that migration factory we can
dive a little bit deeper
into how we undertake that migration and
scaler organized ditches so I have over
to them to talk a little bit about
scaling and migrations action Thank You
Nick so now that we've gone through
building to the business case hopefully
getting into proof we have a technical
approach we made sure the technical and
the non-technical foundations are ready
it's time to get into the actual
migration for the actual migration
execution we often see enterprises adopt
a migration factor we program the
migration factory teams will manage the
overall migration process end to end
the applications will be migrated in
what's called migration waves the
program and approach is primarily driven
top-down within the organization and the
factories aim is to maintain and
accelerate the migration velocity
running parallel to migrate faster while
we have arrived to an overall technical
approach each application will need to
have a detailed discovery and assessment
to make sure nothing unexpected comes up
and this is why you see in each of these
migration factory waves we have an
assess and planned stages for their
specific applications be migrated in
that specific wave to get started you
will build a small and agile pilot
migration team we usually call the
migration team a pod or a migration
squad it needs to have a representation
from the key people that will be needed
or from the key teams that will be
needed to achieve a successful migration
saying application engineers IT product
business people etc to scale and as you
mature some of these banks
we'll move from the migration part
itself to the larger extended migration
team all through the Raj Co e functions
like security engineering business now
doesn't have to be inside a specific
migration part and eventually we see
those migration pods and the majority of
the migration execution work driven by
IT and operations application migration
planning this is one of the most
important tasks for the migration team
without proper planning the migration
might be at risk we generally see large
organizations we Hosting about 80% of
the workloads initially focusing the
transformation efforts in areas where
they can maximize impact but keep in
mind that workloads that have already
moved to GCP even if they were moved
with a simple we hosting can later on be
modernized to leverage more cloud native
services in a much easier way the plan
you build for the specific application
migration application component
migration at this stage might differ
from the default path and even within
that the default migration strategy that
you have defined the various patterns
that can be used for example if you
chose be hosting there might be Rijo
stting into Google compute engine GC we
hosting into Google Cloud fever engine
GC ve free hosting with OS upgrade we
hosting to bare metal etc defining of a
specific application application
component migration path is a primary
outcome of this phase you should take
the overall strategy for the project for
the program together with a specific
pick application data points achieved
through automated discovery CMDB and
information from key stakeholders
gathered through interviews and
questionnaires to decide what's the best
path for this application we continue by
going into the next level of technical
details on the migration how will this
specific application migration be
executed breaking down to more and more
details until we are comfortable that we
have a well-defined viewpoint on how
this migration is going to take place
thank pre and post migration activities
testing strategy automation that should
be prepared in advance etc in parallel
to this technical deep dive you should
plan also further planning on the
migration timing taking into
consideration technical dependencies as
well as business dependencies like
change quizzes planned releases with the
goal of ultimately defining to the
greatest possible degree when exactly is
a race application going to be migrated
identifying what will be the first
worker to migrate is critical I can't
stress enough how important it is to get
it right and when I say getting it right
it doesn't only mean a work out to be
migrated that successfully you want it
to be a workload that is a good
representation of your typical business
work not too simple an application that
you can build up documentation and learn
lessons from think back what was the
main migration goals of the project okay
ideally pick a first mover that will
show the value correlated to these goals
it can be improved performance can be
lower cost something that is measurable
we'll make it worthwhile for the
business to stay engaged you can see
various other considerations and a lot
can be discussed on this topic but if I
had to summarize it in one sentence a
good fast mover will have a high
business value but low effort to
implement and when we talk about low
effort to implement automated tools are
here to help you with that they can
assign a migration beat score
automatically taking into consideration
various factors like operating system
performance age role dependencies count
etc we've talked a lot about people and
processes but the migration Factory
cannot be complete without a very mature
technical angle Google has a variety of
technologies to accelerate migration of
workloads with an emphasis on automation
migration factory methodology works
alongside tools such as migrate for
compute engine migrate for an thoughts
or data migration tools
sois tools and technologies we seek to
maximize value to the business through
accelerating your migration while
minimizing risk and complexity migrate
for compute engine will be the factory's
primary tool for the migration execution
it's built from the ground up to enable
accelerated migration of VMs physical
servers and cloud machines into Google
compute engine it has all the essential
capabilities to support the factory from
built-in testing for you PMS automation
tools to drive mass migration with
minimal Airport advanced networking say
purity features safe and fully
consistent migration and rollback
capabilities and it can even upgrade
legacy Windows 2008 on the go with
migrate or anthos customers can now
automatically migrate and modernize
existing workloads running on prem on
other clouds or even GCE VMS directly
into containers running on gke or on
tops it's a fantastic tool to those who
wish to migrate and modernize benefiting
from cost efficiencies benefiting from
modernized operations management with
the GK and athos advanced tools like
service mash stack driver and the
ecosystem benefiting from modernized app
lifecycle management for maintenance
upgrades patching overall increasing
agility for operations and developers
through the use of migrate for Athens
you can avoid some of the common
modernization challenges especially for
those apps that are not actively
developed or that you don't have access
to the source code apps that you want to
modernize fast without rewriting
optimization is always a constant goal
whether it is as simple as compute
optimization where we have numerous
tools and capabilities to help you
reduce costs optimize performance and
operations dozens of managed services of
ranks that can help you modernize your
applications incremental e or overall
all application modernization
methodologies and frameworks for either
existing
all new apps all the way to easy-to-use
AI and m/l services that will allow you
to further embed innovation faster so
when we say go on what are some of the
biggest lessons learned from large-scale
migration factory programs I think the
first one would be that cloud means
things can be redone don't over plan
one of the fundamental benefits that we
talked about with a factory approach is
the agile execution the constant
improvement leverage that focus on
automation from the foundations to
migration deployment controls automation
is there to help you testing both before
and after have a well-defined view of
what you wanna test and how who is going
to do the testing and make sure you
execute it according to that plan
maintaining velocity is key expect apps
to move up and down the backlog be
prepared for that and you can never have
too much communications and business
engagement never underestimate the
meaning of those status report status
meetings and ongoing regular updates for
the success of the migration program we
are in it together now that you've
learned more about how to make the move
how to build and scale your migration
Factory you're likely asking how you can
get started most enterprises choose not
to make this change alone and seek for
partner to help them with this migration
journey at Google cloud we have a
variety of ways to help you in this
journey including a broad and deep
network of partners our own specialists
professionals
organization that is working together
with this partner medical system a
comprehensive training and enablement
solutions and various documentation to
help you answer your questions around
the way so to recap start with building
your business case address current and
future costs as well as value and value
drivers make sure it's driven by facts
rather than just assumptions seek for
wide consensus to drive your migration
journey forward establish enterprise
foundations that will allow you to scale
quickly both technical and non-technical
foundations like the cloud center of
excellence
chalo migration factory leveraging the
agile methodologies iterate and improve
your efficiency use the right tools to
migrate quickly and if you want to learn
more we have a collection of very
thoughtful white paper that go further
into the details on data center
transformation building a large-scale
migration factory etc over of course
feel free to reach out to your Google
representative thank you very much